Masa amini was a 22 year old Iranian
kurd she was detained in Tehran by the
morality police for allegedly not
covering her hair properly she died in
custody three days after her arrest the
police claimed she died from a heart
attack during mandatory training on the
hijab rules but when images of her
emerged in the hospital in a coma with
bruises they quickly went viral and
provoked widespread anger the protests
which have now been going on for weeks
are the largest mass demonstrations Iran
has seen for years Masa amini's death
has become a lightning rod for many
people across the nation who are fed up
with a religious regime which interferes
in nearly every aspect of their lives
[Music]
the morality police or guidance patrols
are a unit of Iran's police force
they're responsible for enforcing
Islamic dress code in public spaces
according to the law all women must wear
a head covering and loose clothing a lot
of this is open to interpretation which
gives the morality police a huge amount
of arbitrary power on the receiving end
of that power are mostly women although
men can also be arrested those detained
are often given training on the hijab
and how to dress According to Islamic
values the rules are ultra-conservative
and activists have for many years railed
against a system of control which
interferes with what should be a really
basic right how you dress your body
foreign
the death of Masa amini has resonated
with people across Iran and ignited
anger which has been boiling below the
surface for many years at religious laws
which are hugely oppressive protesters
calling for justice and democracy have
been met with a systematic and brutal
Crackdown but people haven't been
deterred because as well as being fed up
with the clerical regime and its
repressive rules people are also angry
at dismal living conditions made worse
by years of U.S sanctions
foreign
has seen widespread protests before but
what we're witnessing at the moment is
different these protests are mainly led
by women and they have the support
across the full spectrum of Iranian
Society Iran's supreme leader claims all
of this has been orchestrated by America
the great Satan and the zionists but
there's no evidence that's the case in
fact what is happening in Iran's cities
appears to be very much an organic
movement to people who are not scared to
defy their regime's rigid Islamic laws
the veil or hijab has long been a symbol
for many of Oppression and many women
are now ripping off and burning their
head coverings in protest no one knows
how all of this will end but it is the
most significant challenge the Islamic
Republic has faced since it was founded
foreign